[Music]
welcome back to Hannity as we report
from Florida tonight rush limbaugh has
been one of the strongest voices against
NFL players protesting our flag our
national anthem and he's one of the
NFL's biggest fans here's what he had to
say earlier today let me go to the NFL
all right I want to read what you said
because I've listened to you all the
years you've been on radio and you're
probably the biggest NFL fan I've ever
known
you love the Pittsburgh Steelers I do
you saw what happened in the Pittsburgh
game and you actually said that you've
been pointing us out it's bigger than
life to you the NFL and for the first
time in 45 years
you weren't excited and that the myth
that you've always had about these these
players in the NFL is gone totally going
down all the government all the I don't
well maybe I hope see that's the thing I
I woke up Sunday morning after president
made his comments in Alabama on Friday
and I'm looking at the way the media is
covering it what's intended to happen on
Sunday
now instead they've hijacked the game
the left has hijacked this game it used
to be a respiratory you know you think
of the players they can do things we
can't do when they're performing an
optimum level it is just incredible to
watch the talent that's on display and
to watch them now get caught up into
something and I don't even think they
understand you know they're backtracking
that well this is not about proper
finger play course it is they try to say
that's how it all got started if they
really wanted to make you think thinking
if one of these players are groupable
called you and said we want a half hour
on your show when you give it to them
100% why did they do that why are they
messing around on the sidelines
disrespecting the flag disrespecting the
anthem what's the point they're not
accomplishing anything except harming
the enterprise whatever's happening NFL
right now it's not how you grow it you
said the owners of clueless you said
this is about race and I think the most
profound thing you said is they're now
being you
used by the left in this country that
wants to take away institutions and the
that the NFL is in a mathema to the left
well you know saying this is risky
because it I firmly believe it don't get
in trouble all get in trouble go ahead
I'm saying that people don't look when I
say what I'm gonna say people go to Rio
home come on are you serious that I just
want to yeah I am and this is why I'm so
concerned I do believe that the left
wants to Indian caused great damage the
NFL what does the NFL stand for
masculinity strength toughness so what
are they doing to it you go to college
campuses now and you'll find classes on
how to take masculinity out of men it's
actually happening there are studies and
courses and college to do this it's
patriotic you've got the flag you've got
the anthem you got uniformed military
personnel all the things that the left
wants to erase from this country they
don't like displays of patriotism
strength rugged individualism and that's
righti the players are being used here
they think it's about police brutality
they think it's about writing social
wrongs and so forth this is an attack on
the NFL as institution for shaking it
down and lowering its profile and impact
on American culture midst of a culture
war everybody knows it the left is doing
everything it can to erase elements of
our country's founding the traditions
and institutions and they don't stop and
once they get their hooks in something
that's why I'm sad about it they're not
gonna let go of this so when I see the
owners they got to be scared to death
they have to be scared to death on the
one hand of they side with their players
linking arms go to the sideline take a
knee or whatever that's just driving the
central fan base away I almost think
that is part of the strategy if you did
want to damage the NFL what would you do
you would do something to cause its fan
base to leave it what's happening this
isn't gonna end well is it not well I
hope it does see I've
I love this so much that I live in
constant optimism this can be overcome
and and we get back to it but the
problem is Shawn everybody in the
management everybody in corporate
America is under the false impression
that this is a leftist liberal country
it isn't it's made to look it because
the media is and the media promotes it
and the media narrative is that America
has progressed and now conservatism is a
minority or that way of thinking is a
minority and so everybody in corporate
America thinks they need to find a way
to convince people to pay them by their
product or whatever is under a
misunderstanding of who their audits
look who advertises the NFL Ford f1
everything that supposedly causes
climate change of a number one
advertised in the NFL guys beer who's
being assaulted and attacked on all this
and the owners and the and the
commissioner I don't know what their
individual politics are I don't think
they understand what's happening to them
I don't think they understand what they
think they're relating to the majority
or fan base they're not they're driving
them away and I hate it I don't want the
NFL to get smaller
I don't want it to become insignificant
I don't want it to be taken over by a
bunch of wusses I don't want it to be
taken over by left-wing social justice
causes you know use something besides
the NFL sideline use something besides a
flag use something besides something
that people use to escape everything
lemon is great for divorce I'll give
them hours on my show now you're Howard
let's see if they take you up on it
seriously I'd like tell me what you care
about I have a big debate I'll bring a
dog two hour long debate what you're
gonna find right this is gonna I think
showing that a lot of I don't know what
the percentages are a lot of these
players really believe hands up don't
you they really look never happened it
didn't happen but the media says it did
yeah and social justice warriors on the
left the civil rights community continue
to say it did you can't blame him if
that's the only media they trust if
that's the only meaning they watch there
there's that aspect of it there are also
the other the police brutality overall
that they think more plaques
in Chicago they have by other black
nobody talks about nobody talk is the
narrative but if they're really
concerned about all of the horrible
things happening to them or African
Americans it isn't happening in the NFL
75 percent of the league is African
American and wealthy and loved and
adored and hero-worshipped and yep it
makes no sense and it just it saddens me
in if I loved it I didn't watch football
Sunday I could i watch college football
well I'm not a big fan of that either
because in cheap uniforms they do look
not as flashy oh I can't I told Lou
Holtz that yeah it was coaching South
Carolina I can't understood what I meant
so we're cool but really it's it's a I'm
gonna be playing golf on Sundays no no I
it's just not song it's not the same
you're watching it and you in the media
can't wait to tell us of all the discord
that I'm suppose I never show the fans
booing though no they don't show are you
the players yeah dissing the flag all
over